sie ist nicht zurück sie ist
zurückgetreten rbb-intendantin patricia
schlesinger die vorwürfe zahlreich unter
anderem ging es um von bild in allen
details enthüllte luxuriöse umbauten
ihres büros einen dienstwagen skandal
und aus rundfunkgebühren bezahlt so
genannte dienst essen in ihrer privat
von der
dreizehnte stock der rbb zentrale mitten
in berlin hier arbeitet sie patricia
schlesinger intendantin des rundfunk
berlin-brandenburg ein bis ins kleinste
detail durch designter arbeitsplatz
bezahlt mit rundfunkgebühren nach dem
einzug in die intendanten etage hat
patricia schlesinger den umbau in
auftrag gegeben nach bild-informationen
ein umbau der wenig wünsche offen lässt
hier ein einblick in die opulente
bestellliste als erstes ließ schlesinger
von einer berliner manufaktur den
teppichboden rausreißen knapp 75
quadratmeter und mit feinsten parkett
auslegen marke kabul warb russe legkow
logisches hochwertiges italienisches
zweischicht parkett vorgeführt vom
hersteller mazzoni toni zocke leisten
und erst pflegepreis knapp 17.000 euro
besonders auffällig weil der fußboden
während schlesingers bevorstehenden
urlaub verlegt werden sollte wurde
entgegen der vorschriften keine weiteren
angebote eingeholt die innenrevision
monierte das wurde aber überstimmt
auszug aus dem beschluss nach
rücksprache mit frau schlesinger so
beauftragen im august 2021 bestellte
schlesinger für ihr büro ein
massagesessel vitalis shiatsu mit wärme
funktion rollbar drehbar farbe creme für
1.299 euro plus 60 euro versand für
knapp 7600 60 euro ließ sich schlesinger
im august 2009 10 eine mit pflanzen
begrünte wand mit automatischer
bewässerung von der berliner firma for
nature system in ihrem leitungsbereich
einbauen doch es wird noch protziger
knapp 60.000 euro kostet die neue
möblierung die juni 2021 mit blick auf
die bevorstehende übernahme des ard
vorsitzes von der berliner filiale der
firma design function angeschafft wurde
unter anderem ein alko kabinen
dreisitzer heimbeck für 12161 eur 2 wie
truck auf high tech 3 sitzer führt
zusammen 10 1612 euro 6 core clock
barroca stapelbar für gesamt
3642 euro insgesamt sind für den umbau
der chefetage für den ard vorsitz laut
projekt des rbb gebäudemanagements knapp
700.000 euro veranschlagt worden
also selbstbedienung der offenbar beim
rbb in der chefetage wir sprechen mit
ralf schuler dem chef des
parlamentsbüros ohne massagesessel bei
uns im studio war grüße dich herzlich
jetzt ist patricia schlesinger weg hat
sie angekündigt zumindest aber auch der
abschied könnte nochmal teuer werden wie
das so ist bei spitzen verträgen hat sie
gesagt ja ich wäre bereit meinen posten
zur verfügung zu stellen hat aber auch
klauseln in ihrem vertrag verwiesen die
darauf hindeuten dass sie entweder die
komplette summe sie ist bis 2026 gewählt
und am haus gezahlt haben möchte das
wären dann rund 1,2 millionen euro
es kann auch sein dass der anwalt ein
angebot gemacht hat eine abfindung
darunter irgendwie auszuhandeln aber
dass sie ihn offenbar noch geld
mitnehmen möchte das ist eigentlich
relativ klar also dass richtet man sich
alles schön ein auf kosten unserer
gebühren sozusagen macht sich schön die
chefetage dann wird man gefeiert und
dann sagt man so ein moment mal jetzt
hätte ich eigentlich gern noch ein
bisschen geld wie wahrscheinlich ist das
denn dass sie so eine summe erhält und
34 es überhaupt möglich dass das alles
passieren konnte man sollte annehmen da
ist irgendeine art kontrolle überwachung
also dass irgendjemand das im blick hat
absolut absolut auf diese abfindung
kommen ja aus den gebühren das muss man
sich halt immer klar machen es ist im
geschäftsleben nicht ganz unüblich dass
man spitzen verträge mit abfindungs
klauseln versieht bzw mit klauseln dass
man auch bei vorfristige beendigung noch
den rest mitnehmen kann wenn es um
öffentliche gelder geht ist das ein
bisschen
anrüchig muss man schon sagen und das
große problem was auch noch dahinter
steckt ist ja nicht nur die tatsache
dass sie sich großzügig
da die chef etage eingerichtet hat
sondern dass er auch die prüfgremien
versagt haben es ist leider im
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk seit
jahren so dass auch die rundfunkräte die
eigentlich kontrollieren sollen dann
gern mal karten in der ersten reihe bei
wetten dass oder anderen großen chance
bekommen oder dass gute berichte aus den
jeweiligen regionen der rundfunkräte in
den sendern auftauchen und dass man da
eigentlich ganz gut miteinander auskommt
die kontrolle funktioniert nicht das ist
eigentlich das ganz große problem und
das dritte was sich an dieser affäre
gezeigt hat diese ganzen informationen
über die anschaffung von vor schlesinger
und auch über die
gezeigten rechnung sie hat tatsächlich
angewiesen dass die geschäftsessen die
personenzahl auf der rechnung reduziert
wird das hat business insider aufgedeckt
dass all dieses möglich ist zeigt dass
sie ein regime geführt hat was dazu
führt dass aus dem haus heraus diese
ganzen informationen nach außen gelangt
sind einfach weil man diese chefin nicht
mehr wollte das ist das andere problem
also da ist sehr sehr viel aufzuräumen
beim rbb beim rbb und in der ard
fragezeichen ist der rücktritt von
patricia schlesinger jetzt das zeichen
problem gelöst oder gibts sprichwörtlich
gesagt noch überall in vielen ländern in
vielen rundfunkanstalten doch diese
massagesessels da müsste man mal genauer
hingucken ich glaube das war ein
besonders schwerer fall von
selbstbedienung was insofern interessant
ist frau schlesinger hat ja lange zeit
das investigativ magazinen des
norddeutschen rundfunks geleitet ihr
mann der auch bei den geschäftsessen
immer dabei war war auch investigativ
journalist beim spiegel sie habe
eigentlich genau das gemacht was sie
jahre vorher niemandem in der politik
hätten durchgehen lassen und dann auch
die gleichen mechanismen gezogen sie
tritt erst vom ard vorsitz zurück möchte
dann aber ihren gut bezahlten posten
doch noch behalten dann tritt sie zurück
sagt das ist eine üble hetzkampagne ist
es keine hetzkampagne gewesen auch bild
hat nur zitiert aus den internen
berichten der anschaffung und
dieses kontrollsystem was ich gerade
angesprochen habe das haben wir in der
tat bei der gesamten ard ich glaube
nicht dass ich in dem maße andere
intendanten auch bereichern aber man
muss einfach genau hingucken dass die
kontrolle und der effiziente umgang mit
den gebühren mitteln dass der einfach
irgendwie eingehalten wird und ich
durchkomme line zwischen den
aufsichtsgremien durchrutschte ralf
schuler vielen herzlichen dank diese
hintergrundinformationen zu diesem thema
[Musik]